Hello and welcome.
It's september 20 2023.
We're at the Active Inference Institute
in the course Active Inference for the
Social Sciences, and here with Mahault
Aberrassen, who will be presenting today
on norm scripts and linguistics under
Active Inference. So thank you,
Mahault, to you. Awesome. So hi
everyone, in as last
time there was a presentation on
semiotics and semantics. I won't dig too
far into linguistics, but I'll touch on
it at the end of the course. So,
what are we going to do? In this module,
we're going to explore the concept of
active inference and its relevance to
social norms and human decision making.
As you will have seen in the previous
classes, active inference is a
theoretical framework that seeks to
explain how organisms, including humans,
engage with their environment to
minimize uncertainty and maintain their
internal states. We're not going to dig
into these concepts too too much,
because I assume they have been
previously explained at length.
However, I will explain how they connect
to social phenomena. So this framework
has significant implications for
understanding social behavior, as it can
help explain how individuals conform to
social norms and make decisions based on
the expectations of others. We'll delve
into the role of active inference in
human societies, emphasizing how humans
and other organisms constantly seek to
minimize their uncertainty about the
world by updating their beliefs and
taking actions to maintain a stable
internal state. This is a crucial
process for survival. It allows
individuals to predict and adapt to
their environment. In the context of
human societies, active inference plays
a critical role in explaining how
individuals navigate complex social
situations, conform to social
expectations, and make decisions that
align with their beliefs and values.
Furthermore, we'll explore the concept
of deontic value within active
inference, which refers to the value
attributed to actions based on their
adherence to social norms and
expectations. By adhering
to social norms, individuals can
minimize the uncertainty associated with
their actions and maintain a sense of
predictability and stability in their
social environment. So together, all
these insights will provide you with a
comprehensive understanding of the
complex interplay between active
inference, social norms, and human
decision making. So let's dive in.
We'll start by introducing a
philosophical framework. Building on the
framework of active inference in
activism offers us a complementary lens
to understand the dynamic and contextual
nature of social cognition. So while
active inference provides the
computational underpinnings for
understanding social norms and decision
making, we still need to anchor
ourselves within a larger theoretical
framework. Inactivism enriches this
perspective by emphasizing the practical
and developmental aspects of social
understanding. So what is
inactivism if it hasn't been introduced
before? Inactivism is a philosophical
stance that extends beyond traditional
theories of cognition, emphasizing the
role of interactions and relational
dynamics in shaping both individual and
social cognition. It argues
that cognition is a dynamic, real time,
fluid and contextual social action.
You can read more about this in ineshi
Bolito's texts and Thomas Van S in 2022.
Generative models and hermeneutics serve
as a cognitive structure and framework
for interpretation, respectively.
These elements are continuously updated
based on social interactions and
signals, thereby facilitating effective
communication and understanding.
Hermeneutics provides a theoretical
framework for interpreting social
signals and cues crucial for effective
social interactions. So hermeneutics
allows for a nuanced understanding of
contextually constituted meaning.
It goes beyond the conventional notion
of self contained objects to explore the
deeper contextual meanings in behavior
and cognition. Yatimer's hermeneutics
offers a way to analyze social action
that goes beyond positivist and humanist
approaches by fusing the conceptual
schemes of the observer and the social
actor. It complements inactivism by
providing the interpretive framework
that are continuously updated through
social interactions, enriching our
understanding of cognition as dynamic,
real time and contextual.
In the realm of social cognition,
inactivism introduces the concept
of generalized synchronization,
which allows for a nuanced understanding
of how social interactions mutually
influence cognitive processes.
The relationship between individual
beliefs and social expectations is
complex, and it's fundamentally shaped
by our interactions with the others and
the world. We thus see that
meaning is coconstituted by the
individual and the environment. If we
adopt an activist and hermeneutics
approach, we find the philosophical
foundations that lead into a
comprehensive overview of the
intersection with social cognition. If
you want more references to read about
these topics, you can ask me at the end
of the class and I can send you a few.
So it's essential to note, however,
that there are some criticisms that
point out the limitations of inactivism
in explaining social cognition. One of
the key criticism is that current
articulations of inactivism are not yet
up to the task when it comes to
explaining complex social interactions.
Despite these criticisms, inactivism
provides a consistent epistemology for a
psychology that is intrinsically social.
Looking forward, the field of inactivism
and social cognition is ripe for
exploration and would benefit from a
deeper connection to active inference.
There has been such research, so
researchers like Maxwell Ramstead
has developed a concept of inactive
inference, which offers a promising
avenue for integrating inactivism and
active inference. His research aligns
with folk psychology and suggests that
these frameworks can coexist and enrich
our understandings of social cognition.
Future other directions could involve,
for instance, integrating inactivism
with other cognitive theories and
exploring its applicability in real
world social scenarios. Through its
connection to active inference, we can
make accurate and testable predictions.
So while inactivism now provides us with
a foundational understanding of
cognition and social interaction, the
concept of agency further enriches this
understanding by introducing more
philosophical perspectives that align
with or diverge from inactivism. So we
can build on top of inactivism through
the notion of agency.
So we will now focus on the key issue of
inactivism, which is how does agency
emerge? How do things self organize
through their interaction with the
environment? Why are they not fully
determined? How can we account for
agency in a system where effectively
self organization is seen as some degree
of determined by the materiality of the
agent and its environment,
agency is a complex construct that has
been explored through a multitude of
philosophical and scientific frameworks.
One prominent approach is the inactive
affordance based perspective, which
underscores the centrality of the I can
notion in shaping both cognitive
processes and behavioral outcomes. So
Maxwell Ramstein again substantiates
this perspective and resonates with the
research conducted by Bruenberg in 2018.
It posits, for instance, that agency is
far from being a mere passive state.
Rather, it involves active dynamic
engagement with the environment.
Current investigations in this domain
are being, for instance, continued by
researchers like Riddipitlia, who is
working on connecting properly the
psychological phenomenon of agency in
active inference modeling. In parallel,
Tom Holtzian Bayesian models
conceptualize active inference as a
Bayesian process aimed at minimizing
prediction error. This model finds
support in the work of Kalan Kopp and
suggests that agency is an active
endeavor who aligns sensory inputs with
internal predictions, thereby fostering
a sense of control and self efficacy.
The cybernetic interpretations offers a
more mechanistic lens, focusing on
control mechanism in homeostasis. In
this view, agency is not just about
accurate predictions, but also about
maintaining a balanced state through
dynamic interpretations interactions
sorry with the environment. Recent
studies highlight the significance of
performance based inferences in shaping
our sense of agency.
That approach suggests that the
congruence between our actions and their
expected outcomes plays a pivotal role
in strengthening or weakening our sense
of agency. So collectively, these
diverse interpretations serve as
intellectual bridges connecting the
domains of philosophy, psychology and
computational neuroscience. They offer
complementary insights that enrich our
understanding of agency, thereby
contributing to the broader discourse on
inactivism and its application in
understanding complex cognitive and
social phenomena.
So how is agency extended?
Deep temporal models and the concept of
agency both focus on the minimization of
uncertainty and the optimization of
decision making. Deep temporal models
provide a computational framework that
can model the complex, time dependent
patterns of behavior and cognition,
offering insights into how agency is
exercised in dynamic social contexts.
In the context of our overall goal of
understanding scripts through active
inference, combining deep temporal
models with theories of agency allows us
to create more nuanced and predictive
models of how individuals navigate
social norms and make decisions through
goal directed actions across different
scales of concern. In social cognition,
deep temporal models help individuals
anticipate and adapt to changes in their
social environment across timescales
that go beyond what would be considered
simply reactive, thereby reducing
uncertainty and enhancing decision
making. An individual can
plan and extend agency beyond the
current moment. So, in the realm of
planning algorithms, deep temporal
models allow us for a theoretical
foundation for optimality, especially
when resources are limited, they enable
state abstraction and cognitive control,
essential elements in hierarchical
planning. Deep temporal models also
contributes to various cognitive
processes, such as action understanding
and language processing, which we will
discuss later. They can be interpreted
and integrated into deep reinforcement
learning algorithms to develop socially
aware navigation policies. Deep temporal
models thus serve as a computational,
again bridge between the neural
mechanisms of action understanding and
the cognitive processes that give rise
to agency.
So what might be potentially a
neural mechanism that allows us to
connect deep temporal models to social
interactions? This is where we bring in
the insights from mirror neuron systems
and active inference. This way we can
have a more comprehensive models that
not only predicts but explains how
individuals exercise agency in complex
social landscapes.
Here, mirror neurons serve as a neural
cornerstone for social cognition,
firing not only during the execution of
an action, but also during the
observation of that same action
performed by another. These specialized
neurons are central to the continuous
updating of internal models of the
environment, including the actions and
intentions of others. They minimize
uncertainty and facilitate navigation
through complex social landscapes,
allowing us for smoother social
interactions and more effective
communication. So here the
deep temporal models are hierarchical
generative models that offer a
computational framework and these models
are adept at handling the complexities
of self agency and other agency.
In the context of self agency, a deep
temporal models affords a high bias or
precision to proprioceptive predictions,
which gives us a nuanced understanding
of one's own actions when
observing another. This bias is
adaptively suppressed, enabling the
system to be flexible and context
sensitive. The interplay
between mirror neurons and deep temporal
model is thus a compelling area of
research. Mirror neurons contribute to
the process of updating internal models,
which is a core function of deep
temporal models. This synergistic
relationship allows for a more nuanced
understanding of action prediction.
We can see a deep and significant
implication for long term planning in
social context. The continuous updating
of internal models facilitated by mirror
neurons and computationally powered here
through the deep temporal models is
crucial for making complex decisions and
planning future social interactions.
There's been recent research that
indicates that our capacity to
understand actions extend beyond the
mirror neuron systems, which involves
the activation of areas signaling
unexpected events. This adds another
layer of complexity to the already
intricate interplay between the neurons
and the models, which suggest that our
understanding of action prediction and
social cognition is far from complete
but is advancing rapidly thanks to these
integrated frameworks. So, given the
ongoing research on mirror neurons,
we have to consider how computational
models like deep temporal models can
offer a more nuanced framework for
studying these neural mechanisms.
So let's try to think about some
of the issues with mirror neuron
research. It's not without controversy.
Some critical reviews argue that there's
no compelling evidence supporting the
role of mirror neurons in action
understanding. Others can suggest that
mirror neurons may be involved in lower
level processes of action perception,
but not in higher level intention
understanding. So we need more studies
to control for premotor contributions to
action perception and provide a clearer
definition of what is meant by action
understanding. This is particularly
important as some research indicates
that there may be no proof that mirror
neurons lead to action understanding.
This doesn't mean that it negates the
importance of these systems. It means we
need more research to make sure that
they are in fact related to action
understanding. The functional properties
of the mirror neuron system indicates
that action understanding may primarily
be based on the motor cognition that
underpins one's own capacity to act.
So we will now consider how these neural
mechanisms can be integrated into
broader frameworks like extended and
optimized active inference. So by doing
so, we can leverage generative models to
provide a more nuanced understanding of
action perception, prediction, social
cognition and adapting behaviors to lead
us to scripts, gender perspectives and
cultural affordances.
We have expanded in time. Now let's
expand in space.
Extended and optimized active inference
represents a comprehensive framework
that bridges between internal cognitive
processes and external environmental
interactions. Generative models serve as
the cornerstone extending beyond the
confines of an organism's brain and body
to incorporate external cognitive
resources such as maps or written
language. This extension not only
enhances the efficiency and accuracy of
these models, but also has practical
implications in various domains like
social interactions and language
processing. If we think of
a cognitive niche,
the framework introduces key dynamics
like selective developmental and
organism niche coordination. The
dynamics elucidate the intricate
relationship between organisms and their
environment, including the reciprocal
effects of environmental modifications
and selection pressures in sequential
dynamics, generative models facilitate
effective communication and
understanding. They allow us to see the
emergence of behavioral and
neurophysiological correlates such as
theta gamma coupling, which we will
discuss later in neural activity, which
can be seen as an emergent property of
belief. Updating under variational
message passing.
Building upon the foundational aspects
of extending an optimized active
inference, it's crucial to delve into
its specific applications in social
context. When we optimize our generative
models through social scripts and norms,
we can see how extending active
inference serves as a practical tool for
navigating and modifying complex social
landscapes aligning with the framework's
broader goals of cognitive niche
construction. So we can see that this
integrates both internal and external
cognitive resources to optimize the
generative model.
Scripts serve as a cognitive blueprint
that reduce the uncertainty and
facilitate successful social
interactions. They are continuously
updated through adapted changing social
landscapes. They enhance the fluidity
and adaptability of social behaviors.
Social norms act as a macro level
behavioral expectation that shapes the
social environment and creates favorable
niches for human interactions. These
norms are internal representations that
help individuals navigate complex social
environments effectively.
So here, cognitive niche construction
involves active modification of the
environment to create those favorable
contexts. Extended active inference
takes this a step further by allowing
for the optimization of generative
models, creating environments that are
not just favorable but also harmonious.
The comprehensive approach here has
implications that span from psychology,
sociology, artificial intelligence and
allows us to potentially set the stage
for future research in cognitive
science. So here we
see that there's an importance to
optimizing internal models for effective
social interactions. So while extended
active inference focuses on the broader
cognitive architecture involving
generative models and social norms,
here we zero in on the role of deontic
value and social conformity providing a
more nuanced understanding of how
individuals adapt and shape their social
environment. So the concept
of deontic value refers to the value
attributed to actions based on their
adherence to social norms and
expectations. It allows us to guide
individual choices. When faced with a
decision, an individual weigh the
deontay value of potential actions
against other factors like personal
preferences, beliefs to determine the
most appropriate course of action.
He'll just allow me one.
So this ties us very nicely to the
notion of agency that we explored before
in Regimes of Expectations by Axel
Constance. We elaborate that deontay
cues enable the environment to learn
about the behavior of its inhabitants,
effectively outsourcing the epistemic
and pragmatic values of any behavior.
You can see that the expansion of active
inference here takes on a whole other
meaning. So active
inference allows for dynamic adaptation,
enables the individual to update their
internal models, better anticipate and
connect to their environment such that
the environment and the individual
mutually model each other. The ontic
value here serves as a common thread
between active inference and regimes of
expectations.
Through these regimes of expectation in
active inference we'll achieve a better
understanding of social conformity and
decision making.
Regimes of expectation centers on the
computational construct of deontic value
which we explained before and
aligns with the broader research on
social conformity, especially the winner
takes all model proposed by Frank in
2008.
Social expectation here play a
significant role in shaping human
decisions and specifically social
conformity act as a learning strategy
which is effective in uncertain
environments. So now that we build on
the foundational role of deontic value
and the regimes of expectation, we find
that this computational construct also
serve as a crucial weighing factor in
individual decision making. So we'll see
how we can put this effect directly on
decision making.
Sorry regimes of expectations have
basically a function of fitness
enhancing social conformity. It suggests
that conforming to social norms has
evolutionary advantages. It leads into
a circular causality between shared
Bayesian expectations and individual
policy selection. It's consistent with
findings by Sanfi in 2014 which
emphasize the importance of norms and
expectations in social decision making.
So now that we have how the environment
and the individual co construct through
these regimes of expectations,
we will find how this allows us to
construct a sense of self, specifically
the social self.
Here, social norms and shared Bayesian
expectations link our individual and
collective decision making processes to
the broader understanding of selfhood.
So how does active inference allow us to
model how we derive the sense of self?
Let's start by explaining the three main
types of selves minimal,
narrative and social.
The minimal self is the prereflexive
experience of being a subject,
emphasizing the body's role in shaping
subjective experience.
The narrative self is shaped by personal
stories and experiences, highlighting
the importance of generative models in
organizing. These experiences aligns
with the active inference, formalism and
psychological desires, providing a
coherent narrative that guides our sense
of self across time.
The social self emerges from
interactions with others and is
influenced by social norms, values and
shared generative models.
This concept is supported by the folk
concept of intentionality, which
includes desires, beliefs, intentions,
awareness and skill.
Understanding these facets of the sense
of self through the lens of active
inference gives us an integrative
cognitive process for emotions and
social interactions. So now we'll delve
more into the intricacies of the social
self to show that the generative model
and social scripts discussed earlier are
integral to its formation. These scripts
optimized through extended active
inference not only guide our social
interaction, but also contribute to the
shaping of that self, creating a
seamless interplay between individual
cognition and collective social
behavior. So,
as we said earlier, social scripts are
the cognitive blueprints that guide
individuals through a myriad of expected
actions or events in social contexts.
These scripts are essentially generative
models that help individuals predict and
navigate social interactions. They're
indispensable. They allow us to
continuously update our internal models
to minimize uncertainty and achieve a
stable internal state. It's particularly
important in a world where social
interactions are increasingly complex
and laden with unspoken expectations.
Its optimization serves as a micro level
mechanism that complements the macro
level influence of social norms and
deontic values, creating a cohesive
understanding of social behavior.
Social scripts can be enshrined in
deontic cues which enable the
environment to learn about the behavior
of its inhabitants, effectively
outsourcing the epistemic and pragmatic
values of any behavior. As we saw
earlier in cognitive niche construction,
the concept of contextual modulation
integrates sensory and motor cues to
influence our actions and decisions,
allowing for dynamic adaptation and
refinement of generative models.
Through this modulation, we can see how
social scripts and norms are shaped and
adapted over time, which promotes the
adaptability in the face of changing
environments of individuals embedded in
that environment.
Now, contextual modulation
here is pretty important and the
mechanism not only refines our
generative model, but also provides the
adaptive flexibility required in complex
environments, which unites the
theoretical underpinnings of active
inference with empirical findings on
adaptive behavior.
So, according to Francesco Donoruma,
action perception is an active
inferential process that combines motor
prediction and hypothesis testing
crucial for understanding social
scripts. Adaptive social behavior thus
results from the dynamic interplay of
socioeffective and socio cognitive
processes. Research by Berg Merza
provides proof of concept that social
context may alter perception, enabling
more adaptive behavior. It's also
supported by studies that reveal how
instinctive behavior circuits in the
hypothalamus dynamically encode spatial
and sensory cues to drive adaptive
social behaviors.
Contextual modulation and social scripts
are integral to adaptive behavior and
action perception, which allows us to
show how social interactions are crafted
through these different scale, these
deep temporal models that integrate
various kinds of priors at different
scales. So here, contextual modulation
acts as a linchpin in the integration of
social scripts into the generative
models.
We can now appreciate how generative
model and social scripts coalesce to
form a comprehensive framework for
understanding interactions.
So active inference is a nuanced
lens to explore how power dynamics
shape shared generative models,
thereby influencing the cultural
affordances available to individuals.
For instance, epistemic communities
serves as platforms where power dynamics
can significantly shape shared beliefs
and actions. Through the construction of
certain niche, we can see that existing
power structure lead to the creation of
environments that perpetuate these
structures through certain kinds of
scripts, certain kinds of norms and
through the valence that we associate to
our sense of self relative to these
scripts. Cultural affordances here
are dynamically influenced by power
tinged asymmetries. These asymmetries
can affect how individuals perceive and
enact social scripts, which further
shapes the cultural affordances that
they encounter.
We see how deeply intertwined cultural
affordances are with power dynamics.
It allows us to understand societal
structures in more depth.
So when we expand the scope of active
inference in cultural affordance
negotiation, we can dive into a case
study that of gender norms and gender
fluidity to broader cultural contexts.
This exemplifies the influence of power
dynamics. So just as individuals
navigate and adapt to cultural
affordances that are deeply shaped by
societal power structures, they have to
navigate gender related affordances that
they also engage with.
So through this, we can also understand
the concept of gender fluidity.
Here, generative model play a specific
role which is to adapt to changing
societal norms and gender related
affordances. These are cultural
affordances dynamic for
maniche construction allows individuals
to create and adapt environments that
reflect their evolving gender identity
and expression.
The concept of affordance negotiation is
particularly relevant here. It refers to
the process by which individuals adapt
their behavior to maximize opportunities
and minimize challenges in their
environment. In the context of gender
fluidity, it involves navigating complex
social scripts and norms that shape
gender expression.
Research suggests that these gender
differences in negotiation are
contextually bound and can be subject to
change. By understanding how individuals
navigate these social scripts and norms,
we can for instance, address the
limitations or constraints that affect
expressions of their gender identity.
So here, gender through the lens of
active inference as a case study and
affordance negotiation gives us a
comprehensive view of the social
psychology and how it can apply to
gender studies, for instance. But this
is true for many other kinds of cultural
phenomena.
So we build now on the understanding of
how active inference and power dynamics
shape cultural affordances.
We can see how this allows us to
understand potentially puzzling actions
which are shaped by social scripts and
the dynamics within the epistemic
communities they inhabit. So we have
defined how scripts allow us to
interpret different kinds of behaviors
and how people navigate their desired
outcomes. Given these social scripts,
so what happens when we are faced with
puzzling actions? People rely on their
generative models to update their
beliefs and expectations. So do we
interpret these behaviors based on
inherent traits or situational reasons?
Here, traits and motives interact with
in predicting behaviors. Channeling the
behavioral expression through one's life
throughout one's life. On the other
hand, contextual cues significantly
influence the interpretation of
ambiguous behaviors. Social scripts
guide our expectation in social
situations can either be adapted when
confronted with unexpected behavior or
allow us to shift from script to script
to have a better prior over what we
might expect next. So for instance,
this challenge is particularly
pronounced for those who diverge from
established social norms and script.
Their interpretations are influenced by
the dynamics of information spread
within their epistemic communities.
Understanding ambiguous social behaviors
is not just about individual cognition,
but also about the social and cultural
contexts that shape our interpretations.
So now we're going to dive from this
point into the specific contextual
factors that further nuance our
understanding. Our former discussion
emphasized the influence of power and
social norms and now we're going to turn
our attention to the impact, say, of
social anxiety, behavioral flexibility
and goal oriented perception in shaping
our interpretations of social behavior.
Understanding social behaviors often
requires an approach that goes beyond
trade based interpretations.
Contextual factors like social anxiety
can significantly influence how we
interpret an ambiguous social cue. For
instance, determining the most likely
prior, using the most likely prior,
rather than being open to other kinds of
interpretations. Behavioral flexibility
is another crucial aspect to consider.
It allows for adaptability and nuanced
understanding of social behaviors across
different social contexts such that a
same script can be interpreted different
ways through different kinds of
behaviors. The concept of goals here
plays an important role in social
perception. They can serve to provide
a broad implication or for where
we understand an individual, to try to
be headed, such that while their lower
level script may be different from the
one we have, their higher level script
is still interpretable.
So now we're going to try to see what
can be the outcomes in real life of all
these processes. Together we're going to
focus on cognitive mechanisms that
underpin social phenomena like
confirmation bias and echo chambers.
Building on the concept of active
inference, we explore how individuals
not only interpret ambiguous social
cues, but also actively seek information
that confirm their preexisting belief,
thereby shaping epistemic communities.
Confirmation bias is a cognitive
tendency that affects information spread
and decision making. It is driven by
agents seeking information that confirms
their preexisting belief while avoiding
challenging information. This is an
effective way of using action to
minimize free energy rather than
updating beliefs in a costly manner.
Echo chambers amplify this bias by
creating self reinforcing loops where
individuals selectively expose
themselves to aligned information. So
research indicates that network
structures contribute to the persistence
of echo chambers, thereby affecting
policy making and public discourse. The
minimization of free energy transfers to
the network, thereby shaping the
environment. We can see here how there
is a loop where the environment both
shapes the individual, who will in turn
continuously shape the environment.
Interestingly, some studies have
identified a reverse confirmation bias
whereby some people actually do seek out
information in an explorative manner,
which again aligns with this idea of
active inference epistemic value. And
here we may try to ponder why
certain people are more likely to break
out of their echo chambers rather than
stay in them. This may align potentially
with deep temporal models, whereas we
can see value at a
later point in time and perhaps focus
more on this expected value rather than
on the direct value of the confirmation
bias. To mitigate
such biases, we can use strategies such
as fostering epistemic change through
diverging information and encouraging
reflection to break apart echo
chambers.
Now we've explored a little bit
confirmation bias and echo chamber. We
can see how this extends to human
communication. This allows us to
explore the principles of active
inference which shape individual
cognitive tendencies and the influence
of the broader dynamics of communication
and collective intelligence on the
environment.
So we can link communicative behavior to
biological imperative of minimizing free
energy, which emphasizes the action
oriented nature of communication. The
framework allows for adaptive behavior
even when the models deviate from
vertical representations of the
environment. So how do we
justify that people lie or that people
say things which don't seem to align
properly with what everybody else seems
to believe about the environment?
Effectively, this is an action. You're
trying to push a belief onto the
environment such that there is a
potential for the environments to be
shaped in a way that evidences your
beliefs. So we
can think of cognitive control here,
whereby active inference has an
effective goal maintenance in working
memory. It provides top down guidance
for overt behavior moving beyond
stereotyped responses. Our understanding
of communication is enriched by
introducing neurobiologically plausible
computational hypotheses. The ecological
approach to active inference is a
framework that understands the
complexities of human communication
across different scales. It explores how
individuals contribute to the collective
intelligence of a group or society by
fostering a collaborative approach that
leverages diverse skills and knowledge.
This is one of the reasons echo chambers
are maintained. They're efficient in the
transmission of information and promote
collaboration among agents who overtly
share a model.
So now we're going to look at a more
detailed understanding of ecological
dimensions of this discourse.
Context, as we saw earlier, plays a
crucial role in the activation of
predictive inferences. Which offers
further support for ecological
approaches. Active inference models
contain terms that encode both the
object of desire and the strength of
desire at the psychological level. So
the context of inactive inference
suggests that generative and recognition
models are best cast as realizing
inference and control under the free
energy principle. So in
this way, communication through the
active inference lens gives us an action
oriented nature of cooperative
communication where together we mutually
craft our models such that we can
achieve a common goal.
So now and lastly, let's dive
into a very short overview of how this
may translate to language processing.
So remember, we discussed deep temporal
models. Here they enable us to explore
the sequential dynamics of language
processing. The models are hierarchical
where inference at higher levels informs
the selection of words at lower levels.
This hierarchical structure allows for
the accumulation of evidence over nested
timescales. One key aspect is the
emergence of behavioral and
neurophysiological correlates in those
sequential dynamics like the theta gamma
couplings that we discussed earlier.
It's a phenomenon that again was
observed and allows us to measure belief
updating under variational message
passing. Thus, generative models
aren't just predictive but also
explanatory. They can help us understand
neural mechanisms like language
comprehension.
So in cognitive control, linguistic can
be scoused as individual agents
contributing to this intelligence of the
group. And the research shows that
generative models are central to the
perception and interpretation of the
linguistic signals. We have a structural
understanding of sequences of words and
their context sensitivity. This enables
the agent to resolve uncertainty about
the underlying conceptual,
semantic or lexical causes of sensory
input. It can incorporate
beliefs about narratives, the type of
question, the scenic state of the world,
a semiotic factor indicating the topic
of discussion. These factors generate
expectations for the lower level, such
as syntax and semantics.
Models enable inference through this
deep temp structure about the narrative
such as those seen in reading.
Here, the neural processes can be
understood in terms of simulating the
epistemic origin seen in reading and
other language related activities.
So, to conclude, we have
seen comprehensive understanding of
active inference inactivism and their
interplay in shaping social cognition
behavior. We have explored various
philosophical perspectives such as the
inactive affordance based perspective,
the Helmholtzium Beijing model, and
highlighted their contribution to
understanding our social interactions.
We've explored deep temporal models as a
potent computational tool for modeling
complex time dependent patterns in
social cognition, such as in language.
As well, we've discussed the role of
mirror neurons, emphasizing their
potential centrality in continuously
updating internal models of the
environment and their significance in
social cognition.
We discussed potential future directions
for research if you are interested in
these topics. So here
the interplay between active inference
and activism. Computational models like
deep temporal models give us a
multidimensional view of social
cognition and agency. It broadens the
scope of research but also brings us
closer to our goal of understanding the
complex cognitive and social phenomena.
So for next class, I offer you
an opportunity. You should pick
a text from this session from the
references that will be made available
or one that you find yourself in the
literature. Read it and try
to explain how it ties to the concepts
that we explored today. Ideally, you can
present it to the group, take five
minutes, explain what the text says and
how it connects to the contents of the
course. If you have any questions, we
can potentially take them now.
Thank you. Mahault. That was epic.
All right, well, people can write
questions in the chat. I'll just read
one. All right.
Where does identity and ideology fit.
In my presentation or in the framework
that I'm presenting? So I'm going to
assume it's in the framework.
Identity fits as a social self, right?
Identity is literally how you craft
yourselfhood relative to the narratives
that you're given. So it's precisely the
social self that we discussed. Ideology
corresponds to a looser,
let's say, weak script that allows you
to shift the valence of certain
values across certain norms. So let's
assume that you understand values
as a higher or lower probability for a
type of level
behavior. So I value kindness. There'll
be a high prior over kindness, and
therefore the paths, the policies that
lead to what I ascribe to as kindness
will therefore become more likely to be
adopted and will become a norm if more
of us value the same thing. The key
issue here is how do I associate the
semantics of kindness to the actual
pragmatic representations and actions
that correspond to what I believe to be
kindness? And this is where the co
construction happens, right? We
communicate together, and I'm going to
say this is kindness. I'm acting on the
world to determine now this is what we
will believe to be kindness. And I value
kindness very highly because that's my
ideology and therefore, this is what we
should be doing. All these things
connect together through the interaction
of the environment, the symbols
encrusted in the environment that I
share and co construct through
communication.
Wow. And how does that have
an impact on affordances, was the follow
up question there.
So if we go back to the part of the
course about affordances, we saw that
certain things are made more likely
given the niche that you are in. If you
understand the onto cues, you see that
there's going to be some signals that
pull you as attractors in a specific
direction. So let's assume that we have
an ideology again that promotes kindness
in the environment. It is highly likely
that potential pathways towards kindness
will be made more available. So,
for instance, let's assume that we
believe that giving money to people is
kindness. There's going to be more
initiatives for you to give money. So,
for instance, I don't know if you guys
have taken the plane recently, but Air
Canada has started program
where if you have loose change in your
pockets, you can put it in the seat in
front of you in a little pocket thing
and you can put the money there and
they're going to donate it. Now, I'm not
saying that's kindness, we can argue
about the politics of it all and the
tax, et cetera, but this is an
affordance that wasn't there before and
now it's in my environment. Now. I don't
have to take it, but it's now more
readily available for me to actually act
on it. And you can see this across every
level. It's just that most affordances
are invisible to us as affordances. We
just react to them, we just exist within
them. But we don't consider they
wouldn't be there, such as a bathroom in
a house. This is one of the things that
allows us to think more critically about
what it means to be homeless. Like to
you, it seems obvious when you need to
go to the bathroom, you'll go to the
bathroom, right? There's a bathroom
available to you, but there isn't one
for people who live outside because they
don't have a home. And yet we've
criminalized the act of relieving
yourself outside. So we've basically
said, well, don't pee. Or if you pee,
well, you're now a criminal. So being
homeless by virtue of not having access
to the same affordances means it's
effectively criminal to be homeless. So
these are the kinds of ways that
ideology shapes our affordances and
effectively pulls us in a state of
attraction and effectively in different
states of power as well. Because we
collectively have decided that the only
people who get to have the right to
certain affordances are the people who
have enough money to live in a house,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Thanks. There's a lot there. All right.
I'll read a comment. This is something
you could address right now or save it
for the discussion or however you want.
Michael wrote would you be open to
attempting to map a social or personal
narrative rather than another element in
the literature, e. G translating The
Hero's Journey or Twelve Step Recovery?
I'm not sure I understand attempting to
map.
Connect the active ontology informalisms
to a more broadly understood narrative
or specific script.
Yeah.
Big fan of the hero's journey. But why
do we want say,
why do we feel like the Hero's Journey
in itself is valuable? We feel that it's
valuable because we feel that it
is a very easy explanation for why
somebody would have value. And it is
usually easy to minimize
free energy through well, there's a
clear path. Right? This person wasn't
the result of very complex interactions
of the environment or whatever. It's
actually no, it's all him. He just
understood the he understood what he had
to do. He figured out what he had to do
and there you go. He was able to do it.
And so this is a signal for
perfect fitness to the landscape,
right? It's perfect cognitive grip. So
it's like there's an underlying
assumption that this one person was able
to update their generative model
sufficiently such that they were
perfectly able to grab every affordance
that the environment gave them to go
towards their state objective.
So in terms of active inference, it's
pretty simple. It's someone that has the
capacity to go from a very unfit
generative model to a very fit
generative model relative to the
environment. And so we like that
narrative because it's like, okay,
well, then that means everybody can do
it, right? If we can go from being
a failure to being a hero, and all we
have to do is take one or two hardships
and go through it, then it's possible.
Now, there's also some deification here,
right, because usually the hero's
journey goes through some very difficult
elements and comes out on the other
side. And we assume that because they
can, there's a rationale of meritocracy,
which is the world is relatively
equal for everybody. So it tries to pull
away from every other power factor,
ecological factor, and it's like, no,
it's all about how you're able to fix
your generative model to do the right
things that you have to do. So that's
why I'm not a fan of it, but I hope was
this the mapping you were looking for in
terms of active inference and free
energy minimization kind of thing?
Here's one thought on that. The hero's
journey or another, archetypal
attractor, just archetype or just
thread. That way, it embeds a concise
narrative account that is made legible
through storytelling that we can
understand. And it embodies
not just kind of mythical things, but
also like, real, structural,
implicit features. That's why some
stories can be so short and so
transferable across contexts, because
they abstract, but also it's what they
do include in those cases. And then you
talked about how that conveys something
about value, which is what supports
social norms and social values, which,
of course, you can't point at anywhere.
Yet what can you say about what
are social norms or forces or what
is the social?
What is the social?
Um,
I think you can point to it. I think you
can effectively point to processes. You
can point to material realities,
institutions.
I think we tend to use
the notion of the social to contrast
it with the notion of the individual.
It's just that nothing's ever that
simple. The individual is always
built because of other individuals.
So there's no really such thing as
uninvival. You're always embedded within
something. So the real question is,
what's the scale that you're interested
in and what is identifiable as
what may be within or without or outside
of your control within that scale? And
we generally make a sort of conflation
between what is social and what is
uncontrollable. Even that's not
necessarily true, as we saw, right?
Because through our actions, which can
be verbal, which can be physical.
We reiterate or push
on what constitutes what is valued by
other actors within the same locality.
So if you're asking what constitutes
culture, well, at the level of
my house, culture is we go to bed
around ten to eleven, because if you
don't go to bed at eleven, you're going
to make noise and you're going to wake
me up. So our shared culture is this.
This is something that we repeat over
time that constitutes an attractor for
more than just me. If I look at the
level of my building, nobody puts
plants outside on their balcony. If it's
at the level of Montreal, there's
potholes everywhere. And we're not
bitching really about it. We've all
accepted there's potholes everywhere.
So it's part of our culture, it becomes
part of our conscious. And so why is it
cultural? It's because we
can see that this behavior, these
expectations, translate not just to you,
to your own model, but it translates to
the model of other people as well, and
they can expect the same for you. It's
something which is definitely shared.
So I think you can easily point to
things once you define the scale at
which it becomes manifest.
Thanks. Really interesting. All right,
a question from Upcycle club who wrote,
in terms of the philosophical dimensions
of agency in active inference,
what is the role of self referentiality?
I think you'd have to define the term,
but if I understand correctly, we saw
that you have to both model yourself and
model the rest of the world in order to
understand whether your actions are
likely to have the effects you want to
have on the world. So this self
referentiality, if I understand
correctly, but I could be wrong, is this
notion of accurately modeling yourself
as that? Does that answer the question?
Yeah. All right. A question from
Michael, who wrote, I work with
marginalized communities who experience
the larger culture as dominant and
scientifically enabled. How should such
communities fortify themselves against
the more skillful extractive cultures?
I mean, that's the main question
that's been for countercultures forever.
It depends what you mean by fortify
yourself. If you mean be less
likely to be extracted from,
I think the question is being extracted
from without getting something in
return. Because effectively, as you saw,
for coordination to happen, you must
provide something for the group in order
for the group to move further. So it's
always a little bit extractive. You will
always expend some degree of free energy
in order to move towards the policy that
you've chosen as a group. So there's two
elements here chosen as a group, and
there should be a return on that as
well. Right? It shouldn't be just you
pay, nobody else gives you something.
So it's the degree to which the system
minimizes everybody's free energy rather
than minimizes this group's. And this
group is still a high free energy, low
allostatic high allostatic load, et
cetera. I'm not the
expert on that. Specifically, I'm sure
there are people who have worked with
marginalized group way more than I have
who could give you better insights. But
from what I've read and if I can derive
from the theory that we've presented
today, you need
to have a strong narrative that supports
your capacity to increase your fitness
landscape and increases and maintains
the bonds, the mark of blanket around
your group. If your group is likely
to dissolve all the time, if it's
constantly threatened
and shaky it's not going to be able to
go very far. It's always going to be in
protective mode. So you need to
ensure that the group has strong bonds,
that the group can expand and that the
group can together enact policies
that lead it to minimizing free energy
and relative to the larger group,
that generally entails having more and
more connections with individuals from
the larger group such that you
are capable of changing
their model little by little. You want
to have a strong boundary but you don't
want to be unable to communicate with
the external group because if you do
that you can't communicate and co
construct. So it
seems trivial, but it's developing,
Allyships, where you have people from
the larger group that become people,
that adopt your message and allow the
expansion of your group and the ideology
or the generative model of your group to
be integrated within what determines the
policies of the higher level group or at
least of the dominant extractive group.
I hope this helps. I know it's not as
concrete as one might want but I'm
sure people with much more experience in
these fields would have much better
answers for you.
I have a question that I've long had
about some of your different research
projects which you presented here.
Often there's this modeling
of both the view from the inside with
phenomenology and also a view from the
outside. So what can you
say about active inference and that,
what does that mean? Where does that
come from? How does that matter for the
personal and the social?
So imagine a mark of blanket.
Every mark of blanket entails there's an
outside and an inside. Now you can
always redraw it, you can always
consider it's wider,
smaller. Inside your mark of blankets
there are mark of blankets. It's all
mark of blankets all the way down. So
this notion of internal and external is
only useful in relation to the
measurement of a joint probability
that's it it's
not ontological. In a sense I can
consider that my cells also have
like an internal model and an external
model and I'm just some emergent scale.
Given the connection between all these
models that have an internal and
external model,
this group right now has a mark of
blankets which means us. We have spoken
and people who have not spoken to us do
not have access to this information here
and in order to exchange information,
they'll probably have to speak to some
of us. And so there'll
be an action that we put upon the world
as a group with some degree of cohesion
over time. So I think we
have to understand internal and
external, really in those terms, in
terms of temporality and objective.
Outside of that, these are illusory
boundaries. They're not real.
And because they're not real, we can
sort of issue essentialism.
If a boundary can always be redrawn
relative to some kind of observer, then
everything is always observer relative.
And there is no such thing as a thing,
which is a thing in itself. It's always
relational, it's always phenomenal. And
how does this tie to phenomenality?
Well, because we
are talking through this mark of
blanket, because we're like, we don't
actually have access to the rest of the
world except through this boundary. The
internal model is what effectively
wiggles relative to the external world.
And therefore you get phenomenality
from this remodeling of the external
world, from this given boundary.
So, for instance, our group's
phenomenality of everybody else is our
shared representation of who that even
means, of what that even means. We have
this phenomenal representation of that
group. We could even potentially create
symbols for them. We could create actual
representations which would become kind
of what would constitutes qualia
at the level of our group. So yeah,
I think I've answered your question. I
get lost in my thoughts sometimes, but
it's great. All right, I'm going to read
a comment from Abel, who just requested
this comment to be read. Avel wrote I'd
like to add some things about the
ideology question. You have a diversity
of definitions of ideology. For the
purposes of the demonstration, I'll
cluster them into two. One, post
structuralist. In this context, an
ideology is any system of value or of
instrumentation of the world. This is
the definition Mahault used in this
case. Everything is ideology because the
basic way we perceive the world is value
ridden. And two, structuralist.
In this context, an ideology is a system
of discourse that dominates a given
social context. For structuralist
definitions to apply, you need a lot
more than shared values. You need a
clergy that maintains and diffuses the
specific discourse underlying the
ideology. I have a limited insight in
the historical evidence, but as of my
understanding, ideology as factor of
mass mobilization is pretty much an
early modern particularism.
I feel like that's if we cast it in
terms of active inference, it would be
the active states, right? Like you need
you need something which acts upon the
world in order to create the self
evidencing you require. And that would
be like the clergy, right? You need to
push these beliefs onto the world. You
can't just sort of let them happen.
Especially if we talk about precision,
right? Because remember, everything
wiggles, everything's always non
stationary. We move, we change, we
interpret, we reinterpret. Those degrees
of uncertainty. So how do we make sure
that we continue over time that we don't
just dilute, that our boundary stays
very strong? That's what I was
discussing earlier with the groups that
want to be avoid extractivism. You need
to proselytize. You need to make sure
that the same narratives we return, we
always return to that same narrative.
And how. If we look at the clergy, for
instance, I don't know if it was a
mistake or not, but for a time, the only
way to preach was in Latin, which means
the only way to access the Word of God
was through these people who not only
had to give you the Word of God, but
they also controlled what it meant.
Because you don't speak Latin, I don't
speak Latin. I'm going to believe you.
You have that knowledge. So it
goes back to these structures of power
where there are some people that have
more access to influencing others,
right? They can push their beliefs with
more precision on others and others just
kind of have to follow because they have
no real way to themselves interpret
and potentially shift narrative
themselves.
When you do that, I feel like I'm
pretty. There'S a lot there.
One part that I thought was very
interesting was variational.
Free energy is about observations. And
in what you had added just recently,
you talked about the measurement of a
joint probability. There has to be like
an aboutness of sensory observations for
that thing. Otherwise it has
not even a sensory it's not even an
inanimate thing unless it has this.
That doesn't mean it's an interesting
thing. And I think that's what the
recent work helps clarify
with this sort of taxonomy from inert to
more classically active control systems
on through just the infinite
possibilities of broadly cognitive
modeling ecosystems of shared
intelligence. Yeah, I think that's a
really interesting, really interesting
distinction you just made. So the paper
by Lance and Co,
maybe that is the key, because maybe
this is a hot take, but I generally lean
towards panpsychism. I do believe that
if consciousness is the substrate, then
everything is some degree of conscious
and we can stop using the word conscious
and we can use the word model right
there's, the degree to which there's a
response between the internal
states of the microblanket and the
external states. So there is some
exchange of information there and
whatever is done with the exchange,
maybe nothing. And this may be the
aboutness your internal model has
no aboutness. It's just there is
information that was inputted and the
only thing that it outputs is a
constants of its boundary. And that's
it. And therefore, in order to have
aboutness, you have to have the
possibility for your internal states to
shift, to move your boundary somehow
towards something more specific, to
segregate, to discretize the
external world into things that have
more or less valence relative to your
very, very akin to what Donald Hoffman
is suggesting, basically.
Building on that. And throughout your
presentation, I got a sense of the
kind of two cultures, the sciences and
the humanities, not that they were
exactly being represented in the talk,
but in terms of excellent style and
classical approach and the non
overlapping magisteria idea that
they're sort of a separable technical
from the social. And even though
it's widely clear that the beliefs
in the moment shape the niche that has
these feedback things, the development
of top down architectures in
some way that become top down
affordances for those or other people at
some future time.
So where do we go from there?
And just like thinking about that space,
how do you approach chapter six of the
textbook in terms of the recipe for the
active inference generative model for
a social setting? For a social setting?
Okay,
I think we
go from semantics and we
map the semantics of a group
and you qualify what that
group is. Maybe the description length
of that group is extreme. Maybe the
description length is my neighbor, your
neighbor, me and three of their cats,
but not the fourth. You know what I
mean? Like maybe there's a cluster there
and we map the semantics of that group
and it's very specific. And then through
those semantics, there's an inherent
causal structures of the structure of
the beliefs through which we could
together, like our own little experts,
try to map, well, okay, what are our
states? What are observations, how do we
map to this? And we try to test that
model and then let's assume that we
disagree. So we're going to have
different kind of breakdowns of reality
and we're going to test the different
models in a sort of Bayesian expansion
or Bayesian model reduction, or just
testing different models and DCM style
and seeing which one maps better to the
expected observations we're going to see
given our model. And you can do this for
anything. You can do this for a small
group of neighbors, you can do this for
a very large group of people, you can do
this for participant research, you can
do this for medicine. I think it's
really about how do people carve nature
at its joints and can they point to the
exact observations which they believe
are part of the carvings or not? I think
that's possible in social sciences,
it's just about taking the
time to formalize how observations
map to the carving together. I think
social sciences generally tend to push
back against a carving.
They will prefer something that
resembles more a manifold.
It ebbs and flows and it's like there's
some prototypical stuff, but mostly
there's stuff that could come in and out
and stuff, and that's fine. You can be
accounted for. So if
you look at different carvings,
we can work them through on a sort of
probability and say, well, this is much
less likely. It's possible, it fits
within the carving, but it's much less
likely. What about this? Well, this is
really like, let's put a probability on
this. And maybe to you, the probability
is that's Frank,
it's in there. I think they'd be more
comfortable with something that's less
binary and something that's more curved
and allows for new things to be added.
Were we to disagree on inclusions, et
cetera. That's a great
point on kind of a narrow note, but to
what you just said there, let's just say
that there's four options. If our prior
is 10 zero, then any
number of evidence times zero stays
zero. So that's like essentially fixed.
And that's when the hyperparameter is
fixed. And then if you enable even a
tiny amount of non
zero value, and so it's like 0.99 and
then a bunch of zeros, then that can
still rise off the baseline. And then
that's the whole question of attention
and cognition, is how do you stay aware
of relevant, salient information,
relevance, realization and all that?
Another point was about the
causal model from the outside, the part
that the person doesn't directly
control. There's no direct control in
the active generative models of action
observations. It has to go through
the niche. That's how the thing is
defined. And so only indirectly can
observations be changed. And so that's
the kind of part that you don't have
agency over, literally. Although the
other glass half full side is that is to
the extent that you do have agency over
that, and then where that glass is and
what narrative actually puts water
into the glass or not, and then what is
the glass half full, glass half empty
part? It brings so much and
just so much like on the personal
thought side. But also it's
just really interesting to see how this
line of research, which was more
qualitative several years ago, like in
the 2016 to 18 time,
and just to see how different motifs
have come into play with the generative
models. So it's a pretty cool
lecture and many people appreciated your
work in the chat, so that's cool. Do you
have any other comments or anything you
want to talk about? No,
but I'm going to have to go in about two
minutes. But I would like to encourage
people to really participate in the next
one, to read some texts and to express
their ideas, because this is how we
percolate percolate. This is how we
percolate good ideas and future
research. And the field of social
sciences is ripe for this. There's so
much that can be done right now,
translated, connected, like we can get
towards a confluent time in research and
science. It all right. Really looking
forward to the discussion and hoping
that people engage in this affordance.
All right, thank you. See you.